[Music]
YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do - 1
2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 that is my texting
community platform doing a lot of
one-on-one engagement in there and also
access opportunity first looks in that
environment - and to 9:30 1 5 7 3 1 join
it now and now to the video you've been
wanting to watch and I'm saying this not
to do anything other than because I know
d-roc is recording right now and I'm
gonna air this in 10 years on whatever
the Instagram of the day is to say I
told you so I promise you that in a
decade 15 years max brand your brand is
going to be the only thing that matters
besides the quality of your product
everything else in the middle will be
commoditized and as you got your
perspective
[Applause]
it's super excited to be here
there's a lot of a lot of things I'd
like to talk about first and foremost
I'm going to spend a couple minutes to
create context of my background because
I think it will really resonate with the
far majority of this room by growing up
in retail and thinking about customer
count and average receipt size on things
of that nature when I got into the media
landscape after building a very large
wine retail and e-commerce business no
question the sector or set one of the
key sectors that I've always felt
closest to is this space we've had the
luxury I had my advertising agency over
the last decade to work with a lot of
fast casual and cue SRS I'm invested in
a lot of that space my business partner
Matt Higgins who's on Shark Tank and
with our se does a ton in the food space
so this is this is very you know it's
funny I I can always feel my own
chemicals I feel so cozy this morning in
this room because I think a lot about
the stuff that I think a lot of people
here think about and more importantly I
think the thing that gives me the great
privilege to be on stage right now as
I've historically thought about the end
consumer in a way over the last 20 years
that has allowed me to have hypothesis
and opinions and executions that haven't
seemed as obvious to the people within
that sector and then has had you know
historical correctness and so I sit here
today at this conference very excited
because I believe that we are living in
a very interesting time of society and
consumer norms completely and utterly
predicated on the fact that the Internet
is now mature you know when I look
around this room there is a vast
majority of us that actually remember
our lives pre-internet
you know I went through all of high
school you know sped up to 18 years old
spending less than 15 hours on a
computer in my entire life I probably
spend 15 to every day now with my phone
and so the biggest thing that I want to
start this conversation
with is the following please understand
that the Internet is now only about 20
to 25 years old as a consumer product
and this now hits scale in a way that I
believe the far majority of this room is
under estimating not only the way
consumers consume information to make
decisions on purchasing your products
but more importantly I would be
flabbergasted if this room isn't already
trying to anticipate things like last
mile things like cloud kitchens things
like that are really gonna impact this
room all of which leads this to one very
large conversation around really the
elephant in the room which is the
internet eliminates the middle that's
what it does by nature the Internet is
actually the middleman the middle woman
and over time every industry and sector
will feel that I actually am really
excited to be here this morning because
what my speeches tend to do is reach one
or two individuals in a room like this
to actually change behavior and the
timing of this talk reminds me of two
significant talks that given to my
career from a timing standpoint four
years ago at a retail conference and six
years ago believe it or not at the black
taxi and limo conference and one
obviously as you can imagine was me
talking six years about ago about uber
and watching the collective naivete and
audacity of the room on how much it
wasn't going to affect them versus how
much it ended up affecting them and then
four or five years ago trying to get
people to understand that the growth of
direct-to-consumer purchasing at the
retail level was really on the cusp and
again because the internet had been
around for a while and Nordstrom's had a
dot-com for a decade and things that
nature the room really misunderstood
what has transpired over the last three
years which is why we're seeing so much
disruption at the retail level because
the cost of goods in actual real estate
and the cogs to operate a retailer
that has a hundred percent you know
brick-and-mortar with an emerging
dot-com four or five years ago was a
humongous vulnerability compared to
consumer behaviors
let it be very clear for this room and I
know it is already even though I don't
think it's sustainable with the delivery
services with the economics both for
them and for you I think you all
understand that the consumer wants it a
certain way consumer doesn't care how we
spend our money on our locations or
where consumer cares about what consumer
cares about the the only reason I think
I've been successful in business is I've
never had a day and this is natural DNA
this wasn't taught this was the luck of
the draw of how I was created there's
never been a day where I've ever thought
about what's in it for me with my
businesses every single thing I think
about every day is what do they think
like why is that good for them what are
they actually doing and so let's break
that down right now there's a couple
things I believe in that I highly
recommend the majority of this room gets
much more serious about prepping for
this understanding some of the companies
in the room boasts both the mergers and
kind of the ikonics
one thing I can promise you is that an
enormous percentage of marketing money
being spent in this industry franchisors
franchisees self owned brand level an
enormous percentage of the money is
going directly in the trash and I think
thank you thank you mom
this is happening in the macro this is
happening in every industry and so this
isn't some wild different thing that's
happening in our sector but it is
shocking to me and as you guys know as
private equity has rolled very deeply
into this industry because I had a lot
of street cred and relationships in that
world
I've been looking even deeper at you
know the dollars being spent and it's
and it's scary let's actually play this
exercise it's a good fresher upper in
the morning get us moving a little bit
by show of hands how many people in this
room now when they watch television
mainly watch Netflix Hulu Amazon or if
they're watching a network show its
DVR'd and they're watching it on their
time don't be lazy
raise your hands high raise them okay
now I need you to keep them up please
keep it up because I see some of you
dropping it please just for me everybody
in the front look because I just kind of
look around I think we can all agree
that this is not a fourteen-year-old
girl crowd right you could put it down I
just want everybody understand what just
happened 90% of the hands just went up
which means 90% of this audience isn't
even capable of consuming a commercial
is it even capable for the rest of us
who during live sports or during the 10%
of hands that went up I think we can all
agree that the second a commercial comes
on television we all grab this and do
something we actually want to do in
those 30 60 2 minutes during that time
billions of dollars are being spent on
television commercials and in 2020
nobody's consuming them Super Bowl on
the other hand I would argue every if I
actually knew your business and knew
your budget if you could afford it I
would spend there first before all the
things I believe in on Instagram or
Facebook or YouTube because you get 100%
consumption by the American population
so this is not a digital versus
traditional argument this is why do we
not mark it with common sense in a 20-19
environment we live in a world where a
lot of the justifications at the high
company levels are completely and
utterly predicated on reporting
potential impressions
you know Millard Braun and Nielsen
reporting just complete and utter
elimination of common sense
we've now this is and by the way I stand
up here with no hypothesis we have now
run multiple a B tests with multiple cue
SRS and fast casuals where we run
Facebook and Instagram isolated on
content and then we run remanent TV
Direct Mail and radio and it's not even
close the problem is 99% of companies
have not taken the time and effort to
actually do an honest a B test at the
highest level somebody makes an
arbitrary decision one way or the other
or more importantly and this is very
important for this room if you leave
with anything hear this very carefully
it is wildly easy to waste a ton of
money doing digital marketing this is
not blanket statement i watch people I
believe that Facebook is so grossly
underpriced for 45 to 90 year old
Americans and you can run incredible
arbitrage on traffic results whatever
you want but I watch people every day
waste a hundred thousand dollars on
Facebook and get no return the ROI of an
execution is predicated on your talent
not on the platform you know the ROI of
a basketball for me is negative I have
two torn meniscus the ROI of a
basketball for LeBron James is billions
of dollars you know this is very
interesting times right now so number
two when we start getting into the
digital conversation the thing that I
think disproportionately changes the
outcome of people's businesses in this
room the reason so many people are
struggling within that environment is
they don't realize that it's the
creative that is the variable of success
people are so caught up right now in a
digital and math environment and they
think about the you know way that we can
target or the digital money that we
spend against amplification they don't
realize that the single piece of
creative or the creative that they're
putting out is the variable of success
I'm running ads I'll give you an example
I sell sneaker
in a JB that I have with k-swiss there's
an ad I ran on Instagram where by
changing the adjectives excuse me by
changing the word hustle to work ethic
the conversion the cost of acquisition
went from seventy seven dollars to
twenty two dollars we're talking about
changing a word in the sentence
most people are running a single piece
of picture across all these different
platforms or video and expecting results
when the reality is what we're living in
right now if you leave with anything
whether you do it an internal or you do
an external if you are a company in 2020
and you have locations like most of you
do if you're not producing fifty to a
hundred pieces of content a day for
Twitter Facebook Instagram YouTube you
are leaving so much uncomfortable
opportunity on the table yet I would
argue because I did my own homework that
there's not a lot of companies in this
room that made a hundred pieces of
content in a year for these platforms
that are different they might have
posted a hundred times but their posts
are the same things so there's an
enormous delta of opportunity hey guys
sorry to interrupt your video I'm just
giving you this call for my number to
let you know that you have to join my
text community to one two nine thirty
one five seven three one two hit me up
with a text one thing that this room has
to ask themselves is the following
are they sales driven organizations or
are they brand driven organizations so
many people here and with the great
sponsor to introduce me I love sales I
love Google Google's great some of these
type in they want a burger in their
local area like it's nice to show up
it's good to show up that's sales let
there be no confusion there are so many
people in this room that are wildly
missing the Delta between a sales and a
marketing organization and marketing and
branding always gets destroyed by CFOs
and short-term operators right nobody I
mean this is why it's fun to deliver the
keynotes like this and have lights on
seeing the reactions we all know
nobody's got the patience to let
marketing play out we now live in such a
quant every
gangee days kind of environment if if
you're lucky on 90 days the reality
though is if you look at the businesses
that the brands that people are baffled
by I see my man from an pizza or Kona
ice or all these things that people are
just surprised that it's doing so well
they are dramatically more brand driven
than they are transactional I mean I'm
just fascinated by our inability as a
collective to understand that and create
new ways to measure businesses to create
new ways to measure your success so for
me the the biggest thing is very simple
we're living in a time where this device
controls our consumers every move you
may not like it personally I watch
people every day and executives every
day make business decisions based on how
they socially want the world to be I
don't have a whole lot of emotion that
kids don't go outside and play like we
did because we're old now like that
doesn't really drive me I'm unemotional
about my ideological Nirvana of how the
world should be I operate when I put my
business suit on which is not
necessarily a suit I operate based on
the reality of the consumer not the way
I want it to be or what got me here over
the last decade
my dad's liquor store was built on
Direct Mail and full-page ads in the New
York Times over my success people think
I did it with social media and I did and
it mattered postgame but I built a very
large business I built that just for
context for the business people in the
room my dad's liquor store was doing 3.3
million dollars in revenue on 10% gross
profit shoppers discount liquors he
meant it right 3.3 on 10% gross I took
that business in a six year period from
that to a sixty-two million dollar a
year business running on 27 percent
gross profit without a credit line and
with no cash infusion from VC or private
equity how I made every marketing penny
work like a dollar at first I figured
out how to do direct mail in the way
that I'm telling you to do social what I
figured out as a child in essence was
that if I made seven different Flyers
that were
more contextual to the addresses in New
Jersey that I was sending that if I sent
high-end wine to Short Hills it would do
better than if I sold everyday wine to
Middlesex it would do better my cost of
the creative was higher and my dad and
everybody else made fun of me for it
because you should pay as little as
possible for the print the postage costs
the most but what I even understood
inherently then as a kid was that the
context of the creative mattered not
just the ability for them to see it
so my conversion rates were dramatically
bigger that led me to the biggest
Nirvana which was in 1997 I started a
very significant email newsletter
because that was a new phenomenon how
many people here were on email in 1997
raise your hands just curious so for the
hands in the room for the youngsters in
here let me tell you about us who had
email 97 we read every single email
remember that it was new we read it we
treated it like actual mail how many
people here are close to their email
marketing or have done email marketing
in their career one more time great
ready for this 90 percent open rates 90
percent open rates in 1997 but like I
know the Sun will come up tomorrow I
know that marketers ruin everything and
I spent the next decade ruining email
and taking that from 90% to 30% because
you know at first it was five days a
week email and that was incredible and
then one miraculous day a year or two in
I was driving to the store I'm like
people read email on Saturday and so we
added the weekend and then the great
downfall of 2004 when I decided people
read email twice a day and we started
emailing twice a day and you know
exactly where this story goes and so
learning the pattern behavior with that
when Google AdWords came out the day it
came out I bought ads and I owned the
word wine for five cents a click for a
month before you Google made a ten cents
floor and before anybody even knew it
existed because I understood context
I was then also good once everybody came
in buying silver oak 1994 Napa Valley
Cabernet and those were my conversions
at five and ten cents that longtail
contextual mentality is the biggest
thing that's missing from marketing
today
the number one reason most people in
here are wasting most of their money is
they're distributing it somewhere people
don't see which is whether remanent
television Direct Mail you know print or
see it at a cost that's effective in
comparison to their business or to when
they go digital they go vanilla it is so
easy to make a piece of creative that
targets an Asian American within a
one-mile radius of your store and
actually have Asian Americans in the
creative it is easy to contextualize
your creative you have to go in a
different mindset you have to put the
dollars into the creative not into the
media amplification that is against all
best practices of the last 50 years of
marketing but that's because the last 50
years of marketing where a television
down mentality and now we're an internet
consumer first up mentality we must
create relevance not potential reach we
must create relevance not potential
reach you have to tell me why you put
something about the New York Jets and
you're creative I'm gonna eat your
hamburger you mentioned something that
we beat the Cowboys I'm in a real good
mood right today contextual the speed in
which that kind of creative to get
consumers to do something is not
inherently native to this industry as a
matter of fact it's not inherently
native to most industries except the
emerging direct to consumer brands that
live mainly on Instagram today
now those businesses are vulnerable
because they've raised so much capital
they're willing to overpay for their
customer and they're actually underwater
something that most of us don't have the
luxury for but because of that they
become lazy and they also do not make
enough contextual creative because they
can afford to buy somebody that's worth
less to them we cannot however what
really is fascinating about actually
taking this consumer centric approach is
this doesn't just matter in marketing
for example I'm dying to know in this
industry when it's gonna figure out that
every late afternoon and every evening
it has a very interesting expiring piece
of inventory that can be converted in
mass
customer acquisition if I owned one of
the businesses in this room the plan
that I would have around food that we
throw out as an offense to surprise them
delight my local community and customers
and record those surprises and delights
and amplify that creative would be at
the top of the things that I would do
you're talking about an asset you're
talking about an asset what we don't
have is a mentality of creating and
campaigning and making ideas live fast
recorded and amplified but we live in a
world where everybody in this room has
an asset that is expiring every night
and having the speed in which turning
that asset into a surprise in the late
moment without undermining the core
product so that people wait for it is an
incredibly delicate and important
strategy that I highly recommend people
debate on very simply to make it literal
taking whatever product you sell and
driving it somewhere or that evening and
giving the high-school football team the
product before the game and filming that
reaction and then posting it on Facebook
and targeting the local area about that
moment becomes the emotional trigger
that makes somebody consider your place
that hadn't before matters the other
thing I'm fascinated by is menu items
I'm fascinated by the math around that
first item that drops off that is in
core that you're always trying to figure
out if we can get one more item to be
core what that means to our economics
and the ability to create marketing
around that 6th 7th 8th item when you go
away from making one vanilla brand piece
of content to a world of thousands all
of a sudden your onion rings strategy
creatively becomes a real game very very
very important very very opportunistic
this leads me down a path that I'd like
to get the people in this room to think
about which is the following if you do
not understand that you were a media
company first comma then a fast-casual
then a cue SR then a restaurant business
you will become very vulnerable I
believe what you're seeing happen in
society politics social issues
everything it's happening in front of
your face
what's happening is communication is the
number one two three and four things
that matter I believe for the executive
in this room that what I'm talking about
right now is not the kind of thing that
you go and hire an agency for or put
your niece in charge of this is
something you yourself have to spend
fifty to a hundred hours to deeply
understand because I believe being able
to communicate in a contemporary fashion
continues to grow in importance on the
outcomes of businesses and is now as
equally as important as being able to
pay your taxes balance your checkbook
and breathe oxygen within a business
environment I believe that marketing has
now become an operational function that
if you really look at what's happening
it is unbelievably impossible to be
successful without having your comms
strategy type strong and remarkably
effective I laugh at the old adages of
ice you know we you know that I think
it's David Ogilvy or whatever it is that
the old adage of marketing right we
spend all this money but 50% of it I
waste I just don't know what 50% that
makes a lot of sense to me as now a
historian of the marketing world the
television print radio that makes zero
sense in 2020 I know where every penny
does everything about everything and
more importantly this is not a sales and
conversion game this is a branding game
let me explain what I mean by that
another tidbit that I would love for
this room to leave with is the following
the biggest mistake that people make
when they do digital marketing is they
think of it as a sales channel a lot of
people go into deal mode or conversion
mode to prove its ROI and what they're
doing is they're hurting their brand and
they're training their consumers to buy
their product on a cycle which hurts all
of our collective margins if you look at
what I do with my content or what other
successful business are doing I'm
treating social as a branding platform
not as a sales platform the content I'm
putting out there is to build brand not
sales that is a very unique execution
that I'm seeing in the marketplace
too many people look at TV or naming
rights or putting your company's name on
jerseys or
it might be as the branding play but
digital as the lower funnel sales play
the the the you know the thing you take
away from the deals that you would have
done a print or Direct Mail I believe
that is a huge vulnerability and that
what people need to understand is the
only way you've ever built a brand in
society is you have somebody's attention
and then you tell a story the attention
is very clear where it is I want to
remind the hands that went up here
television commercials are the most
overpriced way to communicate in today's
society I understand that it dominated I
loved it too I'd be thrilled to do it
it's by the way I wish I was growing up
in the 60s and 70s all I had to do was
convince you to do business with me and
then it was easy one 30-second spot
piece of cake you know which more fun it
is and how much more profitable it is
for an agency to do a 30-second spot
versus doing thousands of pieces of
creative it's it's a lot easier the
problem is it's not where the consumer
is today and now I'm gonna segue into
the real elephant in the room for me
when this came out I ended up making a
lot of money this came out and I said
the smartphone was gonna be the most
important thing ever I wish I was making
content back there because a lot of you
will admit to yourself that you thought
this when this came out almost every
single business friend that I had told
me it would fail because the BlackBerry
was so goddamn good that they couldn't
feel the buttons on this and they got so
good at blackberry they didn't have to
look anymore and they'll never give up
that Blackberry what I know is that
technology always wins always there is a
looming technology in our society that I
think is going to be an absolute tidal
wave to this industry that technology is
the first platform since this that I
believe I'm taking as serious as I took
this this came out and the first three
companies I invested in in 2007 and
eight were Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
it obviously changed the course of my
life
today I sit as a snake in the grass like
I like to waiting for Alexa Google home
Apple pod or whatever voice AI device
actually wins our society norms to
actually hit scale
how many people here have a Google Homer
and Alexa raise your hands now this is
great now as all of you know because the
majority this room does have one right
now that device is very similar to the
first year or two of the iPhone to
remind everybody about year one on the
iPhone and the App Store the number one
app for a long time was the app that it
looked like a beer was on your phone and
you drank it I think people get caught
by technology by not understanding how
it usually works I think we can all
agree right now that Alexa and Google
home were for the most part treating it
pretty basic we're asking for some music
our kids are doing some stuff but this
is not the most important thing in your
life right now however I argue much like
what evolved with the iPhone that the
device in the home is going to
accelerate over the next decade in a
very significant way that when you start
realizing that your Google Calendar is
attached to your Google home device and
you can just tell Google to schedule a
dentist appointment and it will
understand what the perfect time to
schedule it is and reach out to your
dentist and slot it in very quickly over
the next decade we will get very used to
the number one thing we have chosen
forever which is why last model and
delivery is becoming such a big part of
your business which is convenience is
king I don't have to tell this industry
would drive through or with the nature
of a lot of this industry to begin with
versus cooking at home convenience will
always win the convenience structure of
the vice of the voice device in our
society is going to be a very big deal
and more importantly it will lead to the
thing that I care about the most which
is in a world of voice the only thing
left will be brand when the UI is no
longer visual and it is audio only brand
will succeed let me explain it should be
everybody's great fear in this room than
in eight years if I'm sitting in my
living room and I've decided to order
food if I say Alexa order me a pizza
Alexa order me chicken
Alexa order me a burger you better do
well spend the next decade making sure
what comes out of my mouth is alexa
order me a Shake Shack or a PHY or an
and or a Kona you better get there
because you do not want Alexa and Google
and Apple deciding which pizza which
which Chinese food which pancakes I get
delivered because either a the cost of
that Tollbooth will be so great that you
will not be able to afford it or be and
far more likely be it will send to me
the company that they have financial
vested interest in because they own it I
believe over the next decade we will be
in a place ten years from today and real
quick how many people in this room are
retiring in the next five to seven years
and I don't mean you're gonna crush the
execution your company and flip it and
buy an island I mean I mean you're just
[ __ ] old and you're finished okay got
two or three four okay so for the four
of you then in fact enthusing they
raised their hands five you could take
some of these thoughts with a grain of
salt other than I do believe there's so
much opportunity right now to spend your
money more wisely to get customers in
but for the rest of you I highly
recommend you pay attention very
carefully to the last three minutes and
the next two which is the following I
promise you and I'm saying this not to
do anything other than because I know
d-roc is recording right now and I'm
gonna air this in ten years on whatever
the Instagram of the day is to say I
told you so I promise you that in a
decade 15 years max brand your brand is
going to be the only thing that matters
besides the quality of your product
everything else in the middle will be
commoditized and as you know the margin
and the subjectiveness around the
quality of your product is very
uncontrollable there are people that
prefer a white castle over a $35 burger
so that's subjective and very marginal
based what is not is your capability of
building a brand that comes out of my
tongue if you do not go 100% in the
mentality of building brand
you will be uncomfortably vulnerable the
cost of entry to be in your space is
about to collapse because of the virtual
kitchen kitchens at scale people would
build brands and market and everything
else will be a commodity they will and
that's the truth and so I highly
recommend that this morning we really
get serious I come to every speech the
same way which is I'm so flattered to be
there I'm so humbled to be compensated
the way I am I'm desperate to bring the
most value and the way that I know how
to do that is to put the truths that are
actually happening in the system and are
obvious to me on a plate in front of the
audience I know that 95% of the people
do nothing about it
but I am Telling You right now for the
5% here that will consider it here's the
formula here's the prescription you have
to become some you you have to become
somebody that knows how to run ads and
makes pictures videos and audio on these
ten social networks from LinkedIn
Facebook Twitter YouTube you you have to
understand it cold
you cannot outsource this because how
will you hire people or hire partners to
do it if you don't know how to judge it
one of the great things of growing up in
retail was I did everything one of the
great things about vaynermedia is I
didn't know that strategy and creative
and account and media were separate
functions I did them all for myself I
love the feeling of waking up every
morning knowing if everyone quits I know
what to do you cannot be in this room
today and have people quit and not know
how to communicate and market your
company it's over
the cats out of the bag it's what's left
and so all that effort into figuring out
the perfect location because of traffic
and all that arbitrage or the
decorations of within or all those
things they still matter but every
second that goes by they matter less and
the ability to know how to run an
Instagram swipe up ad for $3 CPMs within
a four-mile radius of your store against
44 different pieces of creative to make
all those citizens feel contextual to
then convert into traffic and hire
receipt spend that matters more and will
continue to if you don't have a
tick-tock
LinkedIn strategy for your restaurants
right now you're making a mistake
because they're the two places that have
the most organic reach where you don't
even have to pay for media to build
awareness both seem wildly crazy for
this sector based on what they are
LinkedIn has historically been a B to be
recruiting place which has now become
really Facebook 2012 and tik-tok
everybody thinks is just for 11 year
olds just like we used to think Facebook
was only for college kids don't even get
me started on the fact that the 12 to 14
year old girl in a family usually
influences the mom's buying decisions
and she's the one that actually buys for
the whole household please let's get
more thoughtful please understand where
this is going if you have not committed
to truly acting like a media company
producing content at scale your
competitor will I'm seeing it already
and when we really get at scale of the
infrastructure that allows me or anybody
else to compete without all the upfront
costs of locations and decorations and
all the other variables it's gonna get
very competitive really fast please do
not do what a roomful of retailers and a
roomful of taxi and limo drivers have
done in the past please do not take this
talk for naught the seriousness that I
come with and by the way I have no
interest in being Debbie Downer this is
more of change your strategy understand
what's happening if plenty of time we're
not there yet
but don't do what everybody does and use
that time to be passive and hopeful a
strategy of this never works and I know
this room is smart I know you don't want
it to happen I don't want anything to
happen I don't want every winery to ship
their products direct-to-consumer
that'll be bad for my dad's business but
I think they should if you're capable
why not keep all the margin I know you
don't want it the problem is the
customer does and that is the rub thank
you
I'm freakin old but I'm not finished yet
so in your app if you go to the Gary
Verni event Gary
session at the very bottom they're going
to have a QA we've already got questions
coming in there please add your question
there and we will go from there we've
already got several let's go Gary what
do you think of Bitcoin and blockchain
and how is it going to change the world
so I bought Bitcoin in 2014 so that was
good I wish I bought more I think
blockchain is the one technology in our
society that I'm aware of that has the
ability to be as big if not bigger than
the Internet I also think it's super far
away I also believe that America Russia
and China will do everything in its
power to not let it hit scale because if
you really understand the technology
blockchain it cuts everything out of the
middle including government and I think
that it's a very exciting technology it
is the acceleration of the Internet
itself because what the internet did was
allowed the Facebook's and the googles
and the apples to be in essence the
middle and then everybody else's the
toll booth collector to their toll
booths but I I think it's gonna be a big
technology but I think it's gonna take a
very long time to manifest and I think a
lot of money will be lost in
cryptocurrency because just like search
engines and browsers thousands died one
or two emerged but I think it's gonna be
here I don't think it's something look
the things that even the fact that I
talked about voice is not what I
normally do I tend to talk about you
LinkedIn and tick-tock right now by
influencers on Instagram still it's not
over it hasn't even started it's like
that tactical the reason I wanted to
bring a voice today even though I think
it's five or seven years away is because
it leads you down the inevitable path of
why brand creative is what I want you to
do not transactional from Erin quality
or speed if you can pick only one what
would it be
speed speeds not subjective quality is
simple enough it's very simple I live
with it every day
what is quality creative this what you
know like people like my senior
creatives like well this isn't quality
I'm like based on who you speed is not
animal quality is until it hits the
market and then you could see if it's
quality hence why a religion around a
thousand pieces of content let the
consumer show you what's working not
your audacity Sally asks how will this
changing environment affect supply chain
management to me Sal you'll appreciate
this I haven't spent a whole lot of time
on supply chain management obviously
there's technology advances I am as you
can see I speak with enormous conviction
around what I'm passionate about which
is I spend 100 percent of my time a
consumer behavior what customers are
doing what they're paying attention to
how they're acting
I just haven't spent enough time to give
a great answer on that
what would book beside your own which I
basically have here so that but besides
your own what book would you recommend
or what source should people go to for
information on social media efficacy Oh
actually I wouldn't even read it depends
some like I would never read my own book
because I don't learn by reading books I
so I think you have to first be
self-aware of how you learn but I'll
give you a website that will crush this
for you because you would literally type
in what does a 10 location hot dog
business do on LinkedIn like it's
incredible
I'll spell for you G Oh Oh G oh yeah com
ha I believe that Google for the
inevitable questions in this room are
remarkable if you literally typed in
tonight how do I run ads on Facebook to
raise average transactions spend you
will actually get results and then you
could decide if you're a good reader or
if you're more like me and we'll watch a
video the free information on the
Internet is always better than a book in
my opinion cuz it's contemporary I was
you know what can you throw up my last
slide I want to show you guys something
that's very interesting my last book
crushing it which came out about 18
months ago 24-month I got a really no
two years it nonetheless if you look
above it it's got a bunch of logos
Instagram snapchat Facebook Twitter
podcasting and YouTube if you look at
that book which is only 24 months old
I'm talking about the real blueprint of
what you should be doing yet LinkedIn
and tik-tok are not in it
yet it's the only thing that I want most
of you to do right now if you don't want
to spend money so to answer that
question one of the things like again I
day trade attention I believe most
people do marketing like they buy mutual
funds they make a decision then they go
to sleep I'm making decisions every day
every day you know
instagrams organic reach is clearly
starting to decline so this golden year
of four or five or six years of
Instagram I believe is now starting to
look like what Facebook did a couple
years ago I have to I'm day trading
because the customers living every day
every day a new competitors popping up
against you every day a new diet reports
coming out that way this is an everyday
sting from an anonymous caller to our
channel here with all the focus on AI
and convenience third-party delivery etc
what in your opinion it just moved on me
what in your opinion drives someone to
get out there get out of their house or
office and come into a brick-and-mortar
in other words what's the most important
to the experience convenience like if
your locations happen to be right
outside my office and I want to go hat
like convenience is still King
experience I believe that all of us you
know and I say us cuz my family has a
retail business like our gonna I'm
trying to commit we have this huge
two-story wine shop and I'm trying to
convince my dad to turn the second floor
into something completely different
because you need some rationale for
somebody to come look people are gonna
continue to go to places and eat my
problem is I'm worried how the math
plays out based on the costs you put in
to that it my point to the retailers was
people guys cows people still shop the
square footage cost doesn't make sense
in 2019 like it did in 2010 right so it
doesn't take a lot of behavior changes
for you to be underwater on your
not complicated
so convenience so I still think that
will matter and I think uniqueness I
believe there'll be a day where you
charge for less in the food in your
place than you do for delivery because
you're gonna try to hack them coming in
and that's gonna create even more
friction and so like there's so many of
these things like you've got to be
consumer centric this is what they want
so now how do you do that I believe that
it's convenience and I think it's about
programming I think a lot of us are
gonna get into program listen people
want to go out people want to go out
more than ever
people want to go out to show that
they're out you've seen the extreme like
desert places that are doing well
because their locations are doing well
cuz people want to take a photo and put
on Instagram people are hiking more than
ever they don't want a [ __ ] hike they
just want the photo so I say use the
psychology of consumer behavior one of
the things that I would highly recommend
is create one new item on your menu that
is so ludicrous looking that it makes
people take photos which is the real
reason they come to your place I'll tell
you another thing about doing content
every day I started something that I
want all of you to steal called what if
Wednesday I think every business here
should start something called what if
Wednesday and you make up a food product
you don't actually sell draw it up or
actually make it if you're capable put
it out see what happens now you're doing
R&D on menu items at a very low cost
this is about ideas and making things
for brand cultivation how do you
navigate the current politicization of
the media you know look I think America
is on full tilt we're separating at our
seams and you've got to be thoughtful
you've got to recognize that if you
enter into that fray half your customer
base is gonna go on tilt that's how you
navigate it and if you feel compelled
that that's what you need to do for your
for you as a human you're more than
welcome I jump into certain things I
stay out of other things you know as
we're seeing with the MBA in China you
know like they're very passionate about
some issues they're going the other way
on when it hits their wallet like you
know this is real life this is real life
so my my advice on this is very simple
you do you you know weren't you how you
care about your life your family your
see recognize that history we'll look at
all of this so you're gonna have to talk
to your grandkids one day but at the
same token you can't be ideological
about this we are at a point right now
where we are completely in half and if
you go hard on something half of it will
go the other way and that's fine that's
happened before you know I recommend
everybody doing more history lessons on
the Vietnam War and how business is
navigated during that time and things
that nature obviously what social
there's more amplification there's more
instantaneousness this is not a place
this is a place much like everything I
set up the great Frank I actually gonna
say something funny to you I was about
to say look I'm not trying to impose I'm
trying to observe not say what's right
or wrong no different than what I just
spent the entire keynote on ironically
the best thing that could happen for me
selfishly is none of you take any of my
advice because all of this is just one
scream and if you start running ads and
you start doing creative the cost of my
content goes up and that's my biggest
point I'm very worried for SMBs and
mid-sized businesses not realizing what
comes next which is the following when
coca-cola and GE and and Ford and the
biggest companies in the world really
realize what's going on and they shift
their budgets really here the cost of
getting in front of people is gonna go
up exponentially that's what happened on
search it's really good for us early
people and then the big companies got in
and all of a sudden 10-cent words became
$14 somebody's reading our minds out
there you've got two million to spend on
media and creative how much would you be
spending on content creative that's a
great question I need to there you know
I hate blanket macro stuff but let me
say this way more than you think I'd
probably be spent just on sheer starting
the conversation I'm far more in the 30
to 50 percent than I am 20 percent in
below content is the variable of success
the media when bought right here's where
I'm passionate I believe most of the
companies near are overpaying for media
both in programmatic digital and with
traditional I think there's a better way
to buy it in day trading on marketplaces
on Facebook Google YouTube Instagram
snap all these things LinkedIn right so
all of a sudden I'm saving you I'm
actually getting in front of people
versus potentially getting in front of
people which then I can take that
savings and make
more contextual creative and instead of
making one vanilla piece that cost
35,000 I can make 887 that cost 35,000
and scale scale scale internet trolls
yep
ignore engage provoke or let your fans
deal with them for you
first with internet trolls the first
thing I deploy is empathy because if
you're a human being that is actually
taking time out of your day to consume
something and then spit venom your
life's [ __ ] number two I think you
should engage it I engage trolls I feed
my trolls because I don't think of them
as trolls I think of them as descending
voices that can show all the consumers
where I stand more importantly first you
have to look in the mirror and figure
out if they're right very early on I had
a soup client and it was 2009 if you
remember early Facebook if you posted
something on a brain on a person's page
it would show up like a wall like old
MySpace and they posted pictures of
animals being caged that they were using
for their food products and I get this
crazy email that I have to be you know
they just started social this was also
new and I'm on the phone with the board
and the CEO and they're like you have to
fix this and I'm like no problem let me
ask you some questions number one is
this true yeah but you got to fix it
and I go I can't it's not how the
world's gonna work anymore so I don't
look at it as trolls I look at it as you
know listen when people are saying
egregious things that make no sense you
don't need to engage but if people are
complaining about service or people
complaining about something didn't taste
right things that nature I think it's
actually very smart to engage so that
everybody else can see that you're
listening and you stand by your product
because when you're not replying or
deleting and hiding you're always one
screenshot away of deleting a negative
comment becoming a much bigger story
than the fact that somebody didn't like
the tomato soup you're a strong
figurehead for your company a social
media voice question is can explosive
success be achieved without a human
person
representing the brand mainly it does
very few companies actually use a CEO
for her or him to be the face there's
almost every company doesn't have a
figurehead would you have any advice for
executives in themselves approaching
social media for helping out their
company in sales first be self-aware if
you're introverted and you don't like it
and it's not your scene you don't have
to do it second if you have gift of gab
and you like it and you love people you
should do it but recognize that you have
to spit 100% truth at all times or you
are vulnerable
what should a small independent
restaurant post on LinkedIn and this
also could be referred chain restaurant
yeah I mean look
LinkedIn is crazy organically right now
post I always think about it this way
post something that brings people value
so if you're an independent restaurant
there's a lot of things that come in
value your head chef is funny and you
could just videotape her or him you
could show how you make your product if
you're proud of that and now you get
into the recipes and making business you
could talk about local stuff I still
believe most of you should be the mayor
of your town on Facebook and LinkedIn
we're like ready one store location in
Kansas City that posts on LinkedIn or
Facebook about the pothole on Main
Street and everybody rallies around that
laughs which then leads to them maybe
fixing the pothole at night with their
employees and now becomes a localized
event so so it doesn't have to just be
about your business it has to be part of
the community much like restaurants have
always done a good job with the same
reason that you sponsor the softball
team is the same reason you should make
content about how awesome the principle
is or the pothole or bla bla bla media
company remember I know it's heavy so I
keep trying to reinforce it you're a
media company , you're a restaurant now
all of a sudden you can talk about
sports and weather but you're the news
you can be you really can and of course
if you can do it about your recipes
because you're so proud of your product
that's going to lead to
success how do traditional marketer
shake it off is their conversion therapy
yes I think it's a side hustle if you're
a traditional marketer and you're like I
just sure I would start a side hustle of
buying some product and trying to sell
it on Shopify in Amazon and running ads
on Facebook and Instagram to then taste
what it really works like side hustles
where you force yourself to play small
because you've always played big and
you've lost touch with reality and
you're in theoretics the industry right
now is seeing a lot of virtual kitchens
ghost kitchens dark kitchens what can
the executives do to deal with this and
how do you explain that phenomenon this
is the single most important issue in
this room this is gonna be real bad I
really believe that the only thing I
think you can do is while you've got the
advantage and you exist versus your
competitors that don't exist yet you
have to help brand them now I'm telling
you right now you have to and you have
to be thoughtful in your expansion if
you're gonna build out you know more
locations you have to be more thoughtful
of the cost of goods of opening that up
when you're gonna be competing against
people that don't have that cost and are
gonna pour that money into marketing
this is big I can't stress on you enough
how you need to look at your P&L find as
many dollars as humanly possible for
marketing and then be great at it I
can't I I you know I don't think I've
been around the bush this morning you
have to become an actual practitioner
and strategist and understand er of
contemporary branding because these
virtual kitchens are gonna be a real
problem
they really are you're gonna have 10 new
competitors tomorrow who are gonna take
all the money you spend on location and
staff and all this other stuff and pour
it directly into getting consumers to
pick their product versus yours this is
very real I've been telling this the
CPGs for a long time about Amazon and
Shopify and they laughed at it
much bigger companies than you and
they're competing against much smaller
infrastructure and they're being
affected this infrastructure is far
better and you're far smaller than
Proctor and Unilever
I'm Crafton Pepsi this is real I don't
want this to be like a this needs to be
I need to go act I need to build my
brand at all costs
we have 14 seconds left will the Jets
ever be relevant I think that's fair
based on my tone this morning
of course I will buy the Jets in 22
years I will win a Super Bowl I will
grab the Lombardi Trophy
look in the camera and look at all of
you and say I told you thank you thank
you for this morning I wish you success